hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled confidence in your
calibrators introducing the mass track
endocrine steroid calibrator and quality
control sets this webinar is part of the
clinical
diagnostics and research event and i'm
susie valdez of labyrinths and i will be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roads and sponsored by waters
corporation for more information about
the sponsor please go to waters.com
now let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
first participate by communicating with
other attendees using our new live chat
feature during the presentation you can
find this live chat located on the right
hand side of your screen you can also
participate by submitting as many
questions as you'd like during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you will
also notice that the speaker has
provided a survey located to the right
of the abstract this survey will be
available during both the live sessions
and on the on-demand period
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation simply click
on the help desk button located at the
bottom of your screen within the
navigation bar or from the lobby and
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits link
located at the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits i now
present today's speaker dominique foley
principal and scientist
and clinical applications at waters
corporation dominique welcome you may
now begin your presentation
thank you um my name is dominic foley
and i'm a principal scientist at waters
welcome to this presentation on
confidence in your calibrators
introducing the mass track endocrine
steroid calibrator and qc set
this presentation will introduce you to
a new ivd steroid hormone calibrator and
qc set to help laboratories in their
routine lcms analysis of steroid
hormones
before i take you through the slides i
would like to highlight some key
takeaways from this presentation
the mass track endocrine stereo
calibrator and qt sets provide
metrological traceability the air
laboratories in their compliance to iso
15189
they also provide improvements in
laboratory efficiency through the
provision of lyfolyzed materials
in addition there is greater confidence
in the accuracy of steroid hormone
results
and this provides a pathway to
laboratory method harmonization with
excellent block to lock reproduced
ability
this slide shows the outline of what i
plan to discuss today
prior to discussion of the calibrator
and qce sets i thought it might be
useful to provide some brief background
on steroid hormone metabolism and
analytical challenges associated with
steroid hormone testing
this will be followed by an introduction
to the mass tract endocrine steroid
calibrating qc sets with some of the
associated product characteristics such
as metrological traceability
i will then finally demonstrate the use
of the calibrator in qcs with an
in-house lcms method to provide an
example of method performance using
these products
before i provide an introduction to the
calibrator and qc sets i thought it will
be useful to provide a bit of background
into the steroid metabolism and
challenges associated with steroid
hormone testing
so this slide here demonstrates the key
steroid hormones and associated
associated enzymes that play a role in
steroid metabolism
dysfunction in steroid enzymes result in
significant increases our reduction of
this respective
steroid precursors and products
one example is the reduction of 21
hydroxylase activity
resulting in significant increases in
its precursor 17 hydroxy progesterone or
17 hp
and steroids from alternative pathways
such as 21 deoxycortisol
there is a then an associated decrease
or significant reduction in cortisol
concentrations
analysis of the associated steroid
concentrations can provide an insight
into the function of these pathways
in order to meet the
requirements of a method to provide
insights into stereo metabolic pathways
there are a number of analytical
challenges that need to be met
analytical sensitivity at low
physiological concentrations from some
steroids such as testosterone is
required in order to make the method
applicable across pediatric and female
reference ranges
selectivity is also problematic too as
many steroids are structural isomers
this tends to cause significant problems
with some analytical platforms such as
immunoassay where cross-reactivity of
antibodies can result in problems with
precision and accuracy
although not exclusive to steroid
hormone analysis the preparation of
in-house calibrators and qcs can also be
a challenge in terms of time and
resource
the process in generating in-house
calibrators
can
come
the process in generating enough
calibrations that provide acceptable
data for external quality assurance
samples can take time
this can be particularly difficult with
large numbers of steroids that can often
be found in a single panel for analysis
in addition demonstration of
metrological traceability
may be required to air compliance with
regulatory guidelines
a wide dynamic range for some studies
such as 17 hp and testosterone is
required due to the impact of working
across different
reference ranges which include those
associated with steroid metabolic
dysfunction
in some instances sample volumes may
also be limited but the analytical
sensitivity requirements of a method
will still need to be met
so many of these challenges can be
overcome
using lcm sms
which is why recommendations have been
made to use lcm sms for steroid hormone
analysis
so in regards to these recommendations
there are some guidelines that i wanted
to highlight
particularly two pieces of information
found in this slide
one of which is from clsi c62-a
which highlights the superiority of ltm
sms methods over hplc with optical
detection and amino acid
and this is in regards to selectivity
due to the
orthogonality of lc separation and mass
detection by mass spectrometry
secondly in regards to steroid hormone
analysis
the endocrine society
also highlighted the limitations of
amino acids due to the selectivity
issues and have indicated that
measurements of steroid hormones biomass
spectrometry is preferred
so going back to the metabolic pathway
this slide highlights the challenges
associated with developing an accurate
and precise steroid method
all the steroids shown in this slide are
based on the same a to d ring structure
with small changes in the hydroxyl group
positions side chains and double bonds
these structural similarities are what
can cause issues with antibody
recognition on amino acid platforms
mass spectrometry can provide greater
selectivity
through mass detection
so here is the stereo pathway with the
associated masses of the steroid
hormones
we are able to differentiate some of the
steroids through precursor muscle long
but multiple reaction monitoring
in tandem quadrupole mass spectrometry
is also required to provide greater
selectivity of the isomeric species
however even then there are issues
with some interferences from the isomers
with mass spectrometers
mass spectrometer struggling in terms of
differentiating between steroid items
based on the precursor and products for
the steroids
so those that share the same precursor
can often provide similar product
fragments and these are shown in the
same colour in the slide here
just to give you an indication of the
complexity involved
and in some cases of steroid hormone
excess
you may also find the isotopic forms of
the steroids so the 13 c3 phones may
also interfere with steroids that have a
mass two daltons larger
so there are potential interferences in
the stereo pathway
and these are also grouped by color
one example is the excess of
androstenedione concentrations and these
can appear in the testosterone mrm
transition
as a result of this isotopic
contribution
so in order to work around this issue of
these
interferences the orthogonality of lte
separation provides resolution of these
isomeric steroids
this slide demonstrates
an example of that so by utilizing the
correct column chemistry critical
separations of steroid isomers can be
performed which enhances the method
precision and accuracy
the examples above are typical of the
separation required for lcms analysis of
steroid hormones with separations of 11
and 21 dioxycortisol and corticosterone
separation of 17 hydroxy progesterone
and 11 deoxycorticosterone
and even separation of testosterone and
epi testosterone
so lcms methods in clinical laboratories
are often based on laboratory developed
tests or ldt's
and these are generally validated to
local regulatory guidelines
so these guidelines are constantly
evolving and there is an increasing
demand for all aspects of clinical
methods to comply with these changing
medical regulations
this includes the calibrator and qc
materials used to generate and
independently check the accuracy of the
calibration within the method
so there is a growing need for
metrological traceable calibration
materials to replace in-house prepared
materials in order to add compliance
with these guidelines such as iso 15189
so what is meteorological traceability
so in the context of ltm sms methods
it is a tool to ensure accurate results
it is a process that relates measurement
values to a reference standard and a
property of a test result which is
maintained through monitoring and
correction over time
so in the pyramid shown to the right in
the slide
this shows the level of traceability
typically applies on analytical methods
where sample measurements can be
traceable back through working your
primary standards to a higher order
reference standard
such as nist
so far i have highlighted some of the
challenges associated with steroid
hormone testing
now i would like to introduce you to the
mass track endocrine steroid calibrator
and quality control sets
which can be used to help meet some of
these challenges
so this is the mass track endocrine
calibrator and quality control sets
and these contain 12 steroid hormones in
life of life serum
these include progesterone 11 diox 11d
oxycodocosterone
corticosterone 17 ohp
21d cortisol 11 dioxycortisol cortisol
dhea understand ion testosterone dht and
dheas
there are seven calibrator valves in
total which also includes a calibrated
zero
and three qc valves at low medium and
high concentrations that span the
calibration range
the calibrator and qc concentrations
span the expected reference ranges for
the steroid hormones
in addition to supraphysiological
concentrations
that can be observed in cases of reduced
enzymatic enzymatic activity
in the steroid pathway that i've
described in the previous slide
so the waters massrax solution features
metrological traceability
lock-to-lock consistency
in addition to controlled undocumented
accuracy with a ce ivd mark
this delivers benefits by easing the
path to obtain iso 15189 certification
it also enables longitudinal results
comparisons
and reduces the lab resource burn
through being ready to use an implement
so the mass track endocrine storage
calibrator and qt sets have been
designed and manufactured to assist
laboratories in their compliance with
iso 15189
so
a key benefit to this process is the
improvements in laboratory efficiency
and this is gained from using
the ready-to-use
following reconstitution with water
metrological traceable calibrator and qc
materials
so the table to the right highlights the
end user steps
that are negated
by using manufactured provided
calibrator and qcs
and this results in significant time and
resource savings that can be associated
with the generation of in-house
calibration materials
so just going through this list just to
highlight some of those steps
the lab no longer needs to source their
own crm and matrix for the steroid
hormones
graphometric preparation of standards
obviously is no longer required
and calibrators
are also prepared and these so these are
no longer required to be done because
the mass track endocrine steroid
calibrator set he's already provided
and in addition there are stability
accuracy and lots of lot reproducibility
of the product is covered so this is
taken care of and finally
a measurement of uncertainty can also be
provided too
so the metrological traceability
associated with the mass track and
nicorine storage hormone calibrating qc
sets
is split across two processes
so what we have in this slide is uh
eight of the steroid hormones
and these are primary in-house standards
prepared at our manufacturing site
and these are traceable
to
the crms or the nist material
with the values based on gravimetric
assignments for
uh understand ion 11 dioxide cortisol 21
deoxycortisol corticosterone 11
dioxocorticosterone dhea sulfur dhea and
dht
and then this separate process covers
four of those steroid hormones and these
are secondary in-house standards for
cortisol testosterone 17 ohp and
progesterone
and these are traceable to
the university of ghent and rfb
reference measurement procedures
so those values are based on a separate
secondary reference measurement
procedure assignment
so now we're moving on to more of the
data associated with the product so data
on the accuracy of the calibrator set
was generated through the evaluation of
in-house
qc and external quality assessment
samples or eqs samples
and so we have three lots of
manufacturing material for the
calibrators and these are evaluated for
accuracy mean deviations
from the assigned values at low and high
concentrations
and this was following analysis with an
in-house
validated lcms method
and on the results of which is shown in
the figure
um so this approach not only
demonstrates
the accuracy of the calibrators because
we're seeing deviations within plus or
minus 9.3
and
by doing that we're demonstrating a lot
to what reproducibility of the
manufacturing process
so this is important if laboratories
seek to maintain their harmonization
standards over time
using different manufacturing lots
of the mass trap product
and um
as part of this uh overview i also
wanted to just um reinforce
uh this slide which shows the likely
suitability of using the mass track and
the endocrine storage calibrating qc
sets
in concepts of the walters ibd tandem
quad
ms systems
so they are the dvor tqd tqs micro and
tq xs
so depending on the sample volumes and
sample preparation it is likely that the
dheas cortisol
understand ion and testosterone and 17
hp
as well as 11 dioxycortisol will work
across
all three systems
we're after enable quantification of the
other steroid hormones or 21
deoxycortisol corticosterone dhea dht
and 11 diox cost their own as well as
progesterone
a higher higher end system er
will be required or is likely to be
required
um so just emphasize um as part of the
manufacturing process the calibrators
were assigned
using the uh acuity uplc i class
with z-volt eqs macro system
so we would typically advise a system of
equivalent sensitivity will be required
to accurately determine the law
concentrations
across all 12 steroid hormones
to give you an idea of the performance
of the mass track endocrine storage
calibrator and qc sets in a lab setting
we developed an in-house ltms method to
determine the 12 steroid hormones in a
single method
so this method is based on an
automatable protein precipitation and
solid phase extraction format
internal standard was added to the
samples saw 125 microliters of the life
last serum
and this was precipitated with methanol
and diluted with water prior to
centrifugation
an oasis max micro illusion plate was
conditioned and equilibrated prior to
loading of the supernatant to the spe
clip
10 microliters of the supernatant was
added directly to the collection plate
this ensures uh that some of the
recovery of dhear sulfate
is
is recovered through the extraction
which can be lost through the spe
and this
will maintain the selectivity of the
extraction and therefore analytical
sensitivity of other steroids in the
final extract
law and high ph washes were applied
and the samples were eluted with 60
acetonitrile
already containing this 10 microliters
of sample
35 microliters of the 50 molar
50 millimolar ammonium bicarbonate is
added prior to injection
and the presence of this ammonium
bicarbonate improves the feature for
dhea sulfate
so using the acuity uplc i-class fdm
separation was performed with mobile
phases of ammonium fluoride in water on
methanol
and a cortex c8 column
which is 100 millimeters in length
steps in the gradient solution were
applied to tease apart the isomeric
steroid species
detection was performed using the xevo
tqs macro
system
and the mrn parameters
shown here
should be transferable to the z-volt eq
access
the retention time windows
are also shown in the table
and any lc floor is diverted to waste
outside
these overall retention time windows
so moving on to some of the results
this slide illustrates the
chromatographic separation of the 12
steroid hormones
so separation of some of the key items
which we previously described is
achieved
so we have separation of 21
deoxycortisol corticosterone and 11
deoxycortisone
in addition to the 11 deoxycortical
steroid and 17 ohp separation
so these chromatograms also show an
example of the sensitivity of the law
calibrated from the extraction
with signal to noise greater than 10 to
1 for all the analytes
so moving on to calibration and
analytical sensitivity
the mean correlation coefficient of the
calibrators
and mean signal to noise of the car1
calibrator from five analytical runs are
shown in the table here
so we have some mean r squared values
which are greater than 0.994 across the
respective calibration ranges for the 12
steroids
and the signal to noise of the car 1 was
greater than 10 to 1 across the five
runs
so this does demonstrate that the
linearity and analytical sensitivity of
the method
can be achieved using the mass track
endocrine steroid calibrator set and an
in-house methodology
so now we can move on to
some results around method precision
so total precision and repeatability we
determined by extracting and quantifying
five replicates
of three level qc material
per day over the five separate days
saw 25 replicates in total
so we have total precision and
repeatability of the 12 steroid hormones
across the three concentrations of less
than or equal to 7.7 percent
cv
thus demonstrating excellent method
precision of the of the lcms method
and now moving on to some aspects of
method accuracy in eqa bias
so we have the accuracy of the qcs which
was evaluated in comparison to the
calibrators of the five analytical runs
so the mean accuracy for the qcs or the
quality controls
across the 12 storage hormones are the
three concentrations
range from 91 to 112 percent
accuracy was also assessed for dhea
sulfate cortisol understand ion
testosterone 17 hp and progesterone
through the analysis of eqa samples from
uk and equas
so the data obtained was compared to the
mass spectrometry method mean for the
samples
all for except the altm for progesterone
as lcms method
values
were unavailable for this analyte
and also we've performed at norton bland
agreement on the data set
and this agreement for dheas cortisol
understand our own testosterone 17 ip
and progesterone
provided a mean method bias
that was within plus or minus 7.8
percent
and this does demonstrate excellent
agreements with the eq method values on
method concentrations
for the steroid hormones
so in summary
the
mass track endocrine storage calibrator
and qc set for in vitro diagnostics
contains
metrological traceable calibrators which
aid laboratories in their compliance to
iso 15189
savings in time and resource can be made
by using these pre-made metrological
traceable calibrator and qc materials
in addition the maastricht mass track
endocrine steroid calibrators
are reproducible and accurate across
manufacturing lots and cover the
relevant ranges for each of the steroid
hormones
and using an in-house lcms method we can
demonstrate excellent reproducibility
and accuracy
of the mass track endocrine steroid
quality control set
and in addition we demonstrate excellent
bias and accuracy for the eqa samples
so there are some acknowledgments i
would just like to make um but
generally across the the um
waters
sites around the world there are
different colleagues who have made huge
contributions in bringing this
product to market
so i'd just like to thank doors for uh
contributing
to uh getting this product to where we
are today
and
basically delivering benefits to our
customers
using this product
and so that is the end of the
presentation today so
if you wish to find out more information
you can go to the product page on the
waters website
and this can be found in the clinical
consumables and automation section
on the clinical diagnostics landing page
so if you like to ask any questions then
feel free to do so now
in the q a
or alternatively you may want to contact
your local chemistry account manager who
can field those questions
and provide you with any further
information
so i'd just like to thank you for your
time and i'll just like to pass back to
the moderator now to
help with the q a session so thank you
thank you dominic for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar and if you
have any questions you want to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
so let's get started we already have
some great questions coming in
are there plans to include internal
standards with the calibrators uh in
quality control sets
thanks for the question susie um yeah so
um during the development of these
calibrators and
controls um there were discussions about
including internal standards
um but in the end we decided um there
might not any be any value
to the customer for those internal
standards maybe from a cost point of
view and we know that it is easily
uh
it's a case of being able to get hold of
these internal standards relatively
easily
uh from other
commercial means
to then generate an internal standard
working solution
um for these steroid hormones
so we
decided to
not include internal standards
as part of the product in this instance
thank you so much and our second
question coming in the method to
demonstrate performance of the
calibrator and quality control set use
solid phase
extraction are there possible
alternatives that could be used for
sample preparation of these steroid
hormones
yeah so um we commonly use solid phase
extraction techniques um for our steroid
hormone analysis we know that they do
provide
fairly clean um
almost
fairly clean samples and provide a
concentration effect
to improve analytical sensitivity
there are possible alternatives
using say liquid liquid extraction
and we have demonstrated
a liquid liquid extraction
sample preparation technique for
steroid hormones found in this
calibrator and quality control set
so
it is possible to do it that way
wonderful thank you so much
and we have a final question are there
plans to include any other steroid
hormones such as estradiol
so yeah so um
there is uh
there have been some conversations
around this so we know that um estradiol
in particular is something that is
commonly analyzed
in clinical labs
um but we thought in this instance it
might be worth having a dedicated
calibrating quality control set for this
at some point in the future but not in
the in this kit
at this moment in time
as we didn't see added much value to the
creation of um maybe steroid hormone
panels using the kit
in its current form
um so yeah it is something we are
closely evaluating
um and the same is true for uh
aldosterone as well which is another
steroid hormone of interest
so we are keeping our our ears to the
floor and
just making sure that we are
taking that feedback from customers
and seeing if there is any value in
including other steroid hormones in our
products in the future
dominic thank you for your presentation
today and for important research do you
have any closing remarks you'd like to
provide before we go
um yeah so i'd just like to thank um
everyone for attending the session today
um we really value any feedback so if um
do you like to maybe contact your local
chemistry accounts manager
regarding this product if you are
interested then that would be really
appreciated
and if you have any
interest in finding out more information
on this product then feel free to go to
thewaters.com website where you'll be
able to find that information
well thank you again for your time today
and before we go i also want to thank
our audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions and i
also like to thank our sponsor waters
corporation for sponsoring today's
webinar questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
for two years until november 2023
labrets will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone stay safe bye